the movie begins as we are introduced to
a new horror game called stay alive this
game is still under beta testing stage
so the company has asked a lot of people
to test the game one of whom is a guy
named Loomis in the game he expertly
kills a lot of enemies and moves on to
the next stage which is a haunted
mansion the place is riddled with
several spirits but most of them are
harmless however when loomis's character
climbs up the stairs a woman in red
suddenly attacks him from behind and
hangs him from the ceiling after the
game is over Loomis becomes upset that
he couldn't win but fear and adrenaline
also runs through his veins as he hasn't
played such a realistic game in a long
time later he calls his childhood friend
Hutch and invites him to his place to
play with him however Hutch says he
can't make it so they agree to see each
other later that weekend afterwards
Loomis hears a sound from upstairs and
goes to check what it is but it is just
his buddy Rex and his girlfriend Sarah
having fun shortly after Loomis falls
asleep but is soon woken up by a
nightmare unable to sleep he goes
downstairs to drink a glass of out of
the blue a shadow appears in front of
him which sends Loomis running upstairs
to his horror he finds Rex and Sarah
brutally killed in their room suddenly a
chain wraps around loomis's neck and he
is hanged to death which is exactly the
same way his character died in the game
the next day loomis's friend Hutch is
seen at his workplace his boss Miller
calls him into his office with a very
serious look hatch is afraid that he's
going to get scolded but to his surprise
Miller simply asks for advice on the new
video game he's bought this implies that
he's also an avid gamer gamer bosses are
the best bosses afterwards Hutch learns
about the death of Loomis and his
friends which sends him into a State of
Shock the next day he attends the
funeral and gives his condolences to the
bereaved families as Hutch reminisces
about the good times spent with his
friends loomis's sister walks up to him
and hands him a bag containing her late
Brothers video games she says that her
parents wouldn't allow her to play the
games and that Loomis would want Hutch
to have them shortly after Hutch also
meets the deceased girl Sarah's best
friend Abigail she empathize is with him
and gives him her number mentioning that
he can call her if he needs someone to
talk to oh you don't say after the
funeral Hutch visits his friend October
and her brother Phineas October Comforts
Hutch and helps him grieve while Phineas
makes light of the situation moments
later Phineas finds the stay alive game
in the bag and Hutch reveals that it was
the same game Loomis was playing the
night he died he also adds that Loomis
had invited him to play with him which
he refused after hearing everything
Phineas becomes eager to play the game
but Hutch thinks it's inappropriate
however when a stubborn Phineas asserts
that it could be a tribute to their late
friend he agrees later that day several
other players arrive at Hutch's house
including his other friend swink and the
girl from the funeral Abigail Phineas
and his sister October are also there
after they set up all the devices and
boot up the game Hutch's boss Miller
joins them online from his office before
the game starts a strange prayer appears
on the screen and they are instructed to
read it to start the game the group
naively obliges and after they finish
reciting the prayer the game tells them
that they have made a grave mistake
will die for it however Hutch and his
friends aren't phased by the threat and
they proceed to choose their avatars in
the game The Players must uncover the
horrible truth of a place named the
garage Plantation in order to win the
players have to defeat ghosts and demons
including the main villainous Countess
Elizabeth the players may also use a
rose to escape ghosts that they can't
defeat October remembers hearing about
the story of the Countess but she isn't
able to recall the exact details soon
the game begins and as the others get
busy killing demons Miller makes his way
into a mausoleum inside he explores the
tunnels he also runs out of roses and
soon stumbles upon a torture chamber
just as mellor relays the information
back to his teammates the Countess of
the plantation suddenly appears behind
him and stabs his character in the neck
to death soon October gets bored of the
game and convinces everyone to log off
and call it a night then all of them
return to their respective homes
meanwhile Miller who is still at his
office sees a dark figure running
outside brushing it aside he closes his
office and proceeds to walk away but
suddenly the main door mysteriously
opens again puzzled he returns to
inspect and notices a controller laying
on the floor suddenly the Countess from
the video game appears in real life and
attacks Miller she kills him by stabbing
him in the neck and he dies in the same
way his character died in the game and
people say the rapid evolution of AI art
isn't scary the next day Hutch arrives
at work and becomes horrified to learn
that his bosses died two detectives
Thibodeaux and King investigate the case
and interrogate all the employees when
it touches turn he reveals that Miller
was playing an online game with him and
his friends right before he died hearing
this King starts to suspect Hodge as he
lives awfully near the office that
evening the group again gathers at
Hutch's place to discuss the incident
everyone is shocked by Miller's death
but Phineas just wants to continue with
the game this pisses off the rest of the
group prompting them to leave the room
outside they discuss Miller's death and
Hutch notes that he died the same way as
character did with this theory he
presumes that loomis's death also had
something to do with the game hence the
group suddenly grows worried from
Phineas and returns inside to check up
on him fortunately the nerd is just
smoking and it is revealed that he was
about to die in the game but he paused
it in the nick of time later everyone
that played the game begins to
experience visions and see horrific
scenes searching for answers Hutch goes
to his office and looks up online more
information about the recent deaths he
learns that everyone Loomis Rex Miller
and Sarah died the same way their
characters did in the game stay alive
taken aback he meets his friends and
shares the entire ordeal with them
October believes it immediately and she
tells everyone the story of the garage
Plantation which she heard from her
grandmother it turns out the game is
based on the real life story of Countess
Elizabeth Bathory the Countess used to
hunt for innocent victims in a black
carriage and gut them with silver shears
so as punishment for her since people
had walled the Countess in the
plantation's tower alive the scene then
cuts to Phineas who is headed somewhere
alone as he drives a woman suddenly
appears in front of him causing him to
Swerve his car violently fortunately he
gets out unharmed and calls his friends
for help Phineas also shares that he's
been seeing and hearing creepy things
lately Hutch and the others rush to pick
him up however before they can arrive
Phineas again starts to hear weird
noises much to his horror suddenly a
black Carriage appears and runs him over
killing him instantly later when Hutch
and the others reach the place they find
phineas's Body on the road when they
check his laptop inside the car it's
revealed that even his game character
had died in the same way I don't know
guys I think it's all a coincidence soon
the cops arrive and Hutch tells them
about the game and its relation with the
deaths of the victims but detective
Thibodeau finds it hard to believe and
instead warns Hutch against joking over
such matters meanwhile curious about the
game detective King decides to give it a
try but he quickly loses and his
character dies before Hutch could stop
him as the detectives leave October and
the others become determined to get to
the bottom of the truth Hutch decides to
find out everything he can about the
game while October plans to look for
whoever killed Phineas elsewhere
detective King goes to a game shop to
find more information about the game
however he doesn't find anything and
instead he gets brutally murdered in his
car by the Countess on the other hand
Hutch and Abigail sneak into loomis's
house to find more information about the
game there it is revealed that Hutch
spent his entire childhood living in
loomis's home because his eccentric
father thought his wife was cheating on
him so he burned down their house
unfortunately Hutch was the only one to
survive as his mom perished in the fire
and his dad was sent to prison meanwhile
swink and October are at Hutch's Place
reading books about the Countess in the
garage Plantation just then they get a
call from hotch and October tells him
that she has found a way to defeat the
Countess all they need to do is put
three nails through the countess's heart
neck and forehead to force her human
Spirit back into her body October also
mentions that the contest is afraid of
mirrors and that's the only way to repel
her seconds later they learned from the
news that detective king is dead and
soon after a swarm of Cops show up at
Hutch's Place fortunately swink and
October quickly pack their stuff and
flee through the fire exit after a while
all of them meet up at loomis's house
and realize the game is being played
automatically on swink's computer they
then see October's character on the
screen making them wonder where she is
at the same time October is wandering
outside the house when she sees the
Countess inside an abandoned property
determined to end the madness once and
for all she follows the devil inside
there she picks up a nail gun and
attacks the Countess when she sees her
but to her surprise the attack doesn't
work and the contest remains unharmed
left with no choice October tries to
flee the property but the contest
catches her using a shackle she then
hangs October by the ankle Hutch and his
friends hear her scream and Rush inside
the building to help unfortunately when
they arrive it's already too late as
October has been finished off brutally
later the devastated group heads off to
the address where the Countess has
apparently been locked as all the
friends are dying one by one swink
figures out that one has to keep on
playing so that the others can use this
distraction as an opportunity to
complete their mission in the next scene
they arrive at their location and split
up Hutch and Abigail make their way
inside the Mansion while swing stays in
the van to play the game after a while
swink finds out that the Mansion is
actually the same garage Plantation from
the game so he calls Hutch and helps him
navigate through the house with the help
of the game Hutch wanders around
different parts of the property like the
cemetery and verifies that it is indeed
the real garage Plantation meanwhile
Abigail makes her way upstairs into a
room where she finds a doll that looks
exactly like the Countess she then
enters a wardrobe which leads into
another part of the house there she sees
pictures and articles about the
plantation and also finds the countess's
shears all of a sudden it becomes dark
and Abigail screams out loud prompting
Hutch to run back inside the house he
asks swink where he should go and the
ladder starts unlocking every door in
the game for Hutch to access this is
possible because now what happens in the
game also happens in real life Hutch
eventually reaches the Wardrobe where
the Countess is about to kill Abigail
and in the nick of time swink throws
roses at her in the game causing her to
vanish upon rescuing her hutch kisses
Abigail and the two have an emotional
moment and people say Gamers don't get
babes afterwards the two lesson as swink
tells them to find three nails and get
the Roses while swink is outside talking
to Hutch the van door suddenly closed
with the computer still inside
fortunately right before the Countess is
about to kill his character in the game
he opens the door and saves himself
shortly after the Countess comes for him
in real life even though his character
is still alive with no other choice
swink runs for his life and eventually
trips over a bush of roses meanwhile the
newly formed couple reached the van and
find swink's game character dead hence
they start collecting roses and nails to
kill the real Countess in the tower
suddenly The Carriage comes after them
and Hutch locks Abigail inside the room
he then uses a rose to scare the
Countess away following this the couple
head towards the torture chamber and
then towards the tower where the real
Countess is supposedly locked but
unfortunately the door closes itself and
Abigail gets separated from hush
realizing that they don't have enough
time before the spirit catches up to
them Abigail urges him to leave her and
finish them Mission alone Hutch is
reluctant but after much insisting he
hands her a rose and departs shortly
after he reaches the top of the tower
and finds the countess's body in a
coffin without further Ado he then
starts hammering the nails into her body
elsewhere the countess's spirit is
captured Abigail and is about to finish
her off but before she can do so Hutch
hammers the last nail into her forehead
causing the spirit to evaporate thinking
that the mission is finally over Hutch
prepares to leave but unfortunately the
Countess gets up and all the nails that
were driven inside of her fall to the
ground taken aback Hutch grabs his
reflective laptop and keeps her at Bay
long enough so that he can set the room
on fire however in the process he also
gets trapped and is forced to relive the
horrible incident he suffered as a child
but just then swink comes to the rescue
and saves them with the help of Abigail
it's revealed that he was never killed
because of the rose bushes he fell on
top of then the three friends quickly
flee while the evil countess's body
Burns in the tower a few days later a
video game shop receives a copy of the
stay alive game which he finds very
interesting and in no time the store
starts selling several copies of it the
movie ends as the Countess once again
emerges from the tower ready to pounce
on more victims subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching